mr. speaker corona virus continues to
spread throughout the world the latest
figures show that 17,000 337 people have
sadly died here our hearts and the
hearts of the whole house go out to
their loved ones I know that across the
house we are united in our determination
to fight this virus with everything
we've got and today Mr Speaker I wanted
to update the house on each part of our
battle plan first the resilience of the
NHS I can tell the house that for the
first time we now have over 3,000 spare
critical care beds in the NHS that is
more than three times more than we had
at the start of this crisis it's thanks
to the incredible work of an awful lot
of people that we now have this extra
spare capacity even before we include
the new Nightingale hospitals over the
past two weeks I've been lucky enough to
attend either in person or virtually the
opening of four of these new
nightingales in London and Manchester
Birmingham and Harrogate and there are
several more to come all across the UK
in Belfast in Glasgow and Cardiff Exeter
and Sunderland these incredible efforts
from dedicated staff supported by our
armed forces mean that our NHS has not
at any point been overwhelmed by
coronavirus some said this would be
impossible and today I want to reinforce
the message that non covert NHS services
are open for patients the NHS is there
for you if you need advice and treatment
and I want to address very clearly this
message to those who might be vulnerable
to heart attacks or stroke to parents of
young children to pregnant women and to
people with concerns that they may have
cancer I want to emphasize that people
with non coronavirus symptoms must still
contact their GP if you think you need
medical help please contact your GP
either online or by phone to be assessed
if you need urgent medical
nice use NHS one-one-one online or if
you can't get online call one one one
and of course if it's serious or
life-threatening call 999 if you are
told to go to hospital the place you
need to be is in hospital the NHS is
their field and can provide the very
best care if you need it the second
point of our battle plan is on supply
and working to boost supplies of core
equipment now the full weight of the
government is behind this effort and
again we've brought in the Armed Forces
to help us meet this demand this
includes ventilators both purchasing
extra stock and increasing the
production of new ones
we now have record numbers of
ventilators with 10,700 available for
use for patients it includes medicines
so we can make sure everyone has access
to the supplies and treatments they need
and of course it includes personal
protective equipment - in normal times
the NHS PPE supply chain supplies 233
hospital trusts currently 58,000
separate health and social care settings
are being supplied with PPE so we're
creating that whole new logistics
network from scratch and we have some of
the best minds in in the country working
on this I'm grateful to colleagues from
the NHS public health England the crown
commercial service cabinet office
communities Department MOT the Armed
Forces again devolved administration's
territory offices the business
Department of Treasury the Foreign
Office and the Department of
International Trade because they are all
playing their part and last week I
appointed Lord Dayton who delivered the
Olympics to a new role in driving
forward PPE manufacturing here since the
start of this crisis we have delivered
over a billion items of PPE and we're
constantly working to improve the
delivery system and buying PPE from
around the world we're also working to
make more at home and I'd like to thank
the UK businesses who've generously come
forward with offers to turn their
production lines to part of this
national effort and I'd also like to
thank members from across the house who
put us in contact with businesses in
their constituencies we're actively
engaged with over a thousand companies
who buy from abroad and working with a
hundred and fifty-nine potential UK
manufacturers we have a rigorous system
of verifying the offers that we receive
because not all offers have been
credible and it's important to focus on
the biggest most credible offers first
this work is crucial so we can get our
NHS and care staff the kit they need so
they can do their job safely and with
confidence the third part mr. speaker is
to scale up testing I've set the goal of
a hundred thousand tests a day by the
end of this month and I'm delighted to
say that the expansion of capacity is
ahead of plans even though demand has
thus far been lower than expected we are
therefore ramping up the availability of
this testing and expanding who is
eligible for testing to make it and
making it easier to access the tests the
tests are conducted in NHS hospitals
through our drive-thru centres mobile
units and home deliveries these tests
are then sent to laboratories
we've completed the construction of
three lighthouse labs in Milton Keynes
Glasgow and Cheshire each site - took
just three weeks to complete and begin
testing and as we reach have reached the
peak and as we bring the number of new
cases down so we will introduce contact
tracing at large scale the introduction
of the new NHS Act for contract tracing
is also in development and as we do this
we're working closely with some of the
best digital and technological brains
renowned experts in clinical safety and
digital ethics so we can get all of this
right the more people who sign up for
this new app when it goes lives the
better informed our response will be and
the better we can therefore protect the
NHS fourth mr. speaker we need to make
sure the best possible we make the best
possible use of sign
and research to pursue the vaccines and
the treatments that are essential to
debate their virus once and for all
and here the UK is at the forefront of
the global effort we've put more money
into the global efforts to search for a
vaccine than any other country and
yesterday I announced over 40 million
pounds of funding for the two most
promising UK projects Imperial and
Oxford and the vaccine for this Oxford
project will be trialed in people from
tomorrow and I'm sure the whole house
will agree this is a very promising
development and I'll repeat what I said
yesterday which is that in normal times
reaching this stage would take years and
the combination of this innovative group
of people at the Jenner Institute in
Oxford and the MHRA the regulator who
deserve our special praise because they
have both ensuring that the process is
safe yet is also conducted more rapidly
probably than ever before and they
deserve the support of the whole house
in that work at the same time we'll
invest in manufacturing capability
because if either of these vaccines work
then we must be able to make of them
available for the British people as soon
as humanly possible the fifth measure I
will talk about mr. speaker in the time
available is the one where everyone can
play their part social distancing and I
just want to thank everyone from across
the country for their steadfast
commitment in following the rules
including in this house it is making a
difference we are at the peak but before
we relax any social distancing rules or
make changes to them we have set out the
five tests that have to be met first
that the NHS can continue to cope second
that the operational challenges have
been met third that the daily death rate
falls sustainably and consistently
fourth that the rate of infection is
decreasing and most importantly fifth
that there is no risk of a second peak
finally mr. speaker we're working to
protect the most vulnerable through
shielding this is the sixth part of our
battle plan that
in a huge effort underway across
government to contact and support those
at risk
we've been boosted by the support and
the help of the heroic NHS volunteer
responders who signed up in their droves
within two days of our call to action
and unbelievable three-quarters of a
million people put themselves forward
for this initiative so with the
volunteers and with the support of the
communities Department and the NHS and
local councils who've done amazing work
on this that we are shielding the most
vulnerable mr. speaker these are
unprecedented times for us all and we've
all seen the extraordinary impact of
coronavirus in our constituencies and
across the country
and even though today we are physically
separated this house is at its best when
we are united in our purpose and our
resolve so I will keep working with
members right across the house in this
fight against this invisible killer
because this may be a akin to a war mr.
speaker but it's one where the whole of
humanity is on the same side and I
commend this second to the house